here's some good news the president of
China in the United States just met in
San Francisco and one of the things they
discussed was pandas a few decades ago
China gave a bunch of pandas to the US
National Zoo here in Washington DC as a
sign of friendship and diplomacy but
recently they took the pandas back
because of the increasing tensions
between these two countries but after
this meeting between these two
presidents Cen ping suggested that they
should send the pandas back as a gesture
of their friendship I mean it's kind of
bizarre that diplomatic relations
between the two most powerful countries
is being measured in pandas but hey I'll
take it if you want a better understand
global politics follow along for more